welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of the
Mandalorian season 3 episode 4 Chapter
20 The foundling referring to Ragnar
Vizsla who at this point has got to be
begging the covert to find a new
training spot because good Lord just
Spar inside but also referring to the
Fountain grogu whose escape from the
Jedi Temple was finally revealed
delivered by Jedi Master Keller and Beck
played by Ahmed best before playing
Master Keller in on the kids game show
our man played Jar Jar Binks I feel like
it's Ahmed who was found and we who are
found let's break down this Victorious
episode seen by scene for the details
you might have missed and by the way if
you're going to WonderCon new rockstars
is hosting a panel on Friday March 24th
at 2 30 PM we'd love to see you there
and subscribe to our new channel the
Deep dive and you can support our
growing network with Armando inspired
shirts at nerdriot.shop if you grab one
of these you can write in a custom shout
out that will feature in our Wookie
leaks after shows okay this episode
opens back on the covert of the children
of the watch with the blast of this
instrument
[Music]
feels like this started the covert's
morning of training but also something
perhaps done an attempt to ward off
Predators good luck with that we pushed
in on this Waterfront from both the air
and then from the water the two places
that their animal predators will attack
them from on this Waterfront we see the
covert training into hand combat against
each other and against dummies fighting
with staff scaling walls with wires and
shooting the water which at first seems
random but if you think about it they're
actually doing this to ward off attacks
from that giant dinosaur Gator who
attacked them last time again would just
be easier to train in the cave but the
armor is like no I like to put my feet
up take this rough housing outside we
see parents fighting with vibroblades
and flamethrowers but grogu our little
sensitive boy the classic kid who
probably prefer a Fisher Price wishing
well here is playing with some crabs who
crawl past him like at squid game Red
Light Green Light
[Applause]
tells him to put down the Rocks but dad
they're not rocks they're shells grugu
can see life in detail where others see
nothing as din takes grogu away notice
how all these rocks rise and Scurry into
the water grogu shares a calmness with
animals that others do not have the
crates behind him as they train are
stamped with a mythosar symbol and some
mandoa letters it's so hard to translate
mandoa but I'm pretty sure this is f or
n o c Dash G and then
f-er-n-o-c-j grogu is paired up with
Ragnar that's a foundleine who is
baptized in chapter 17 played by Wesley
Kimmel remember in his baptism he did
not finish the Creed could that be why
he was cursed to be taken by the animals
of this planet din says that grogu needs
to rise from foundling to apprentice
apprentice it's just interesting to see
the parallels between the dogmatic order
of the mandalorians and the dogmatic
Jedi Order mandalorians 2 have a ranking
hierarchy similar to the Jedi Jedi
ranking goes young Lane Padawan
Apprentice Knight Consular Guardian
Sentinel and then Master now during the
sparring session in the background the
armor Empire Visa watch on they take
Keen interest in grogu and Ragnar says
that if Goku is too young to speak to
create and get a helmet he's too young
to fight but then says one does not
speak unless one knows a line from the
Creed which says a lot about why din is
a strong and Silent type but it also
applies to the end of this episode
pokotan speaks to the armor claiming to
have seen them at the Tsar but the armor
doesn't refute her claims she only talks
past them because one should only speak
if they are speaking with absolute
certainty pokeaton says her dad was the
same way as din making this a second
reference to Boca town and satine's
father Duke at an icrease make me think
we might see a flashback to the craze
family when the girls were the ages of
Anna and Elsa do you want to join the
Death Watch grogu performs acrobatic
Jedi leaps and plugs Ragnar three times
with paint darts and then says he didn't
teach him that referring to grogu
learning all these jumps during his time
with Luke Skywalker on the book of Boba
Fett these flips aren't the kind of
moves Yoda used when dueling Dooku in
Attack of the Clones as Insidious in
Revenge of the Sith also the kind of
moves we saw yaddle do when she fought
Dooku and tales of the Jedi but then a
flying Raptor snatches Ragnar and Dan
and paws and two others follow I love
how there's this jetpack mounted shot
showing the jet pack in the foreground
gassy now at the same time as the one
behind him gases Out Pass runs out too I
just appreciate that we get some
limitations on the watch's flight
capabilities they're not able to fly and
fly and fly forever like Iron Man with
his Perpetual Arc Reactor their packs
would have a limited amount of fuel
bocaton Pilots are Gauntlet after the
Raptor and both are framed in the sun
low in the sky very similar shot of the
Tie fighters framed in the sun and the
force awakens that I've always loved and
both are not to the helicopters in the
sun and the Apocalypse Now poster
bogoton returns from scouting to show a
map of the Raptor's nest and Dent says
it flew a long way which suggests that
the Raptor went beyond its normal
hunting territory again this cult seems
cursed by the wildlife of this planet
bogoton says these are no higher than
the peakset kirimore I used to climb
them in basic training a line that
sounds a lot like Luke's saying I used
to Bullseye womp rats my t16 back home
they're not much bigger than two meters
kirmore is a remote stronghold on
Mandalore home of the squirasha clan
from the Legends novel Republic Commando
true colors and its sequel order 66. the
armorer orders paused to take the shrie
training team team srikak is one of
the sigils of House of Isla and of the
death watch that's the three-prong
scratch on the pauldron of the one who
saved din when he was a kid thank you to
betterhelp for sponsoring this video
movies and TV can be great escapism but
when it's time to face things head on
better help is here to help better help
is the world's largest therapy service
and it's 100 online with better help you
can tap into a network of over 25 000
licensed and experienced therapists who
can help you with a wide range of issues
to get started just answer a few
questions about what you're looking for
from therapy and what your preferences
are better help will then match you with
a therapist from their Network that's
right for you after that talk to your
therapist however you feel comfortable
whether that's via text chat phone or
video call you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge better
help gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com new
rockstars that's B t t e r h e l p.com
Slash new rockstars for 10 off your
first month of therapy grogu watches
them go and toddles after the armor and
the puppetry and the effects of this
movement just get better and better as
he enters the forge we see it all from
his lower point of view he was there in
chapter 17 but now Den is not with him
so rather than seeing this from dim's
higher angle it's from grogu's angle
there's a moody crust dissolving Forge
montage is the armorer lectures just as
we shake the steel we shape ourselves we
all begin as raw or we refine ourselves
through trials and adversity during this
Roku is superimposed over the beskar ore
as it's poured into the mold as if to
show grogu himself being molded refine
ourselves through trial and adversity
might be why this cult continues to
train in such a hostile environment but
this metaphor of seeing ourselves as
metal comes from Plato's The Republic
the myth of the three Metals in which
Plato posited that human beings were
created with one of three medals in our
souls gold silver or iron or bronze
which defines the role the person should
play in society gold for philosopher
king silver for warriors Brown funds for
Craftsmen and Farmers the children that
watch similarly liken themselves with
beskar which they believe cast
themselves as these dogmatic Warriors
the armorer says the forging process
reveals weaknesses as grogu is framed
directly behind this hydraulic press so
that it looks like he is the one being
crushed over and over the Sparks of the
press match cut with the Sparks of the
blowtorches as this door in the Jedi
Temple is being cut open and yes we are
back and order 66. this forging process
had the same EX effect on din Jordan
back in chapter 3 and season one it
caused him to flashback to the day the
Death Watch rescued him and discovered
him as a foundling the framing of the
two flashback sequences is pretty
parallel din's doors opening on a
separatist Droid Light coming in through
the slit like the slit of his visor that
Droid later killed by a death watch for
grogu it was the doors being pried open
by the 500 first clone troopers followed
by elevator doors opening to his Jedi
savior but here four Jedi defend grogu
from clone troopers of the 500 first
they yell get him to kelleran so this
tells us that during roku's time in the
temple he must have been known to
several Jedi Masters and that there was
something of a plan in place to secure
grogu if something ever happened grogu's
bassinet is the same one that he started
the series in in the pilot episode but
now it is clean and new the same red and
white colors of the Jedi Temple wall
surrounding them not yet scuffed up so
this right now was not far from where
grogu was during his flashback in
chapter 6 of The Book of Boba Fett so
this flashback is picking up right where
we left off and presumably there could
be a next part flashback that picks up
after grogu and Keller and blasted
hyperspace Carl Weathers directed this
episode and he did an incredible job
with the sequence holding the tension on
the elevator doors and then whoosh we
opened to kelleran Beck Ahmed best who
played Jar Jar Binks in the prequels and
he played Jedi Master Keller and Beck
host of the Jedi Temple challenge kids
game show in 2020 which unfortunately
got discontinued during coven best has
spoken in interviews how he
intentionally wanted to host that show
not as himself but as a Jedi character
to help kids playing and watching
suspend their disbelief use the force of
your core now I'm at best unfairly took
some horrible abuse from the jar jar
haters so it just feels so great to have
this shot from guru's point of view so
that it feels like we are being rescued
by Ahmed best and this show is rescuing
him I can't think of a more appropriate
Redemption for an actor who went through
so much and it just shows that lucasfilm
produces these shows with love also in
addition to Jar Jar Binks best played a
course on Clever Ahmed Beck an attack of
the Clones and he has said that Keller
and Beck is related to that character
hinting that that game show hosts
character was Canon and the past and now
it confirms it Kellerman has some
interesting gold stitching on his robes
that was not on his robes in the game
show the gold plus the white inner layer
of robes is closer to the Jedi wardrobe
we saw in the high Republic era Temple
archives librarian jocosta new had
similar embroidery on her guard kelleran
picks up the blue lightsaber the Jedi
who fell in the elevator and double
fists on the clone troopers these clone
troopers call to each other
yeah they brought back somewhere
Morrison to voice these I love how I'm
at best place this with such intensity
like he makes specific eye contact with
each the Trippers engages and he emotes
specific betrayal for each of them he
Force pushes the Clone Trooper off the
ledge from the hand that he's actively
holding the blue lightsaber in see I did
this when I have a Chipotle fountain
soda and I try to pry open a few spare
fingers to open my apartment door
without spilling too much of the coke on
myself so I'm a Jedi master too but
thank goodness some of those clone
troopers showed up when they did because
there was their Speeder bike with that
convenient jump seat that Keller and
grogu used to escape as he Zips away
from the burning Temple there is a line
of traffic on the left side of screen at
first I thought these ships might be
leaving the temple and there might be
other Jedi survivors out there but
really it looks like a distant line of
traffic that's passing the temple in the
background kelleran is pursued by an
laat a low altitude assault transport
that's the Clone Trooper gunship that we
first saw and attack the clones and
kelleran steers into a train tunnel just
like the tunnel that we saw Pershing and
Eli Kane riding through chapter 19.
Keller and beers off into the station
for Monument Park the same Plaza that
Persian came toward several decades in
the future after this this is the one
that has the highest peak of Coruscant
umate and yes again this is the same
place that Obi-Wan it's a team toward in
Clone Wars they end up crashing on the
platform with a Naboo crew user this is
an h-type Nubian yacht not exactly the
same Royal Cruiser that Amidala used in
Phantom Menace this is more like the one
she and Anakin use traveling to Tatooine
and Geonosis and attack of the Clones so
does this mean that Kellerman took grogu
to Naboo or that figures from Naboo like
Padme or shiv Palpatine or Senator Binks
might have known about grogu as well
well the guard who helped scalarin is
listed in the credits a senate Guard
Captain but they are wearing the same
red padding as the Naboo Royal security
forces from the prequels so I'm
wondering if these could be security
detail of a senator from Naboo like
Senator Amidala or Senator Banks so if
Padme knew about grogu presumably Anakin
would too so I don't think it was Padme
Palpatine knew there's no way he would
let the clone troopers kill such a
valuable Target so Palpatine obviously
didn't know so jar jar is looking like
the likeliest option here jar jar really
is the key to all of this with the Ahmed
best connection I think that's likely
who it was and you know what I don't
have a problem with that but taking
grogu to Naboo right now would be
incredibly dangerous though I guess they
didn't stop Ahsoka Tano from visiting
bail or Grana at padme's funeral roll on
Naboo and tales of the Jedi what was she
thinking ultimately kelleran was just a
total surprise pick of who saved grogu
so I'm guessing grogu's next destination
will be some new place we haven't heard
of yet though I think whatever that path
was might end up being the path that we
saw in Obi-Wan Kenobi where Jedi
refugees were taken along and grogu was
just the first one to be taken along
that path grogu looks up to see two
b-wing starfighters roaring in they have
a similar howl of the later type
fighters from synar systems that the
v-wings were Republic era predecessors
too and kylo ren jumps to hyperspace and
the clangs of the armor Hammer intake
Roku back so back in chapter 17 when
grow who saw this pergol in hyperspace
in that moment he might have also been
flashing back to his traumatic Escape
which is why he snuggled up with
denjarin right then the armor completes
the rondelle with the Sigil of the mud
horn that was a Signet didn't jarin
chose after grogu saved him from one in
chapter two bogoton's rescue party with
the shrie Cox are seven in total
everyone besides din is blue helmeted
meaning they're all from house besla the
fact that it's seven mirrors the Seven
Samurai or the Magnificent Seven which
is based on the Seven Samurai under two
crescent moons they make camp and
bocaton asks Den how to eat when others
are around the answer is apparently just
go be alone and you eat your shame in
private that's the way I gobble up my
Chipotle alone in my car before I meet
up with people pause says that poketan
as leader of this war party gets the
honor staying by the fire and I guess
the honor is being well lit enough so
that Katie Sackhoff gets actual screen
time this episode but this is just some
interesting rituals here the leader
needs to stay the warmest and the safest
to keep the war party overall intact
Boca time leads its war party because
she as she said she said experience
climbing and Mandalore and she's just
the most experienced to this group
because this covert otherwise is no
really defined leadership other than the
armorer being their High Priestess Paz
warns that the Raptor will likely kill
the foundling if it is attacked like it
doesn't say it'll kill my son he says
the foundling as in this is a youth who
is a responsibility of the entire tribe
as they climb the sound of their cables
mixes in part of the sound of the
lightsabers igniting yeah you hear the
burst release but without the Searing
burn sound and the hum that follows it
rather the wobble of a metallic cable
that follows it now they climb up to the
nest where horrifyingly there is a best
car helmet of one of the past kids the
Raptors snatched and there are some
buzzing insects around that dry grass
likely swarming some currently Rotting
Flesh Paws Leroy Jenkins is Into The
Nest where three giant infant Raptors
attack the mama Raptor coughs up Ragnar
one could only imagine what he went
through but we know Boba Fett's
Mandalorian armor helped him survive
inside the sarlacc either way Ragnar
here is bone dry just a bit odd Raptor
takes off with both Paws and Ragnar and
we know flying off until their jetpack's
run out is its tactic so there's a
natural ticking clock to this Chase
bogoton gets swatted by a wing and she
loses one of her night owl pauldrons you
do see it here which the Raptor you
could say might have done her a favor
the animals of this planet Guided by
simple nature or Guided by some
spiritual Force to get these cultists to
where they need to be while the others
just piss off the Raptor with their
cables only broke a ton sticks she hooks
it sticks a vibroblade above the eye and
the Raptor releases pause it's din who
snares the wing and immediately Viper
blades to the Talon before the Raptor
can wriggle free Ragnar's loose and
didn't Scoops him up and we hear a blast
of the flute so interesting to point out
here Boca time goes for the Giant Eye to
tame the Beast like her connection with
the Giant Eye of the mythosar jinjarin
saves the kid like his connection with
grogu the Raptor flails in the water and
there's always a bigger fish he gets
snapped up by that same Gator species as
the one we saw in chapter 17. like the
Moses are eating the Pteranodon in
Jurassic world now in chapter 17 that
guy got blown up this one proves that
the water is filled with these big boys
Paws adorably pulls his son in close and
din watching them upon return
immediately picks up grogu so seeing
pause fear for his son gave him his own
fear for being apart from his little boy
they brought back the three Raptor
babies no clue how they all fit on that
ship without the Raptors trying to eat
them on the flight back but this will
provide some beastly flying mounts that
this clan can ride alongside bokoton
when she inevitably rides the mythosar
the armor makes a new pauldron marked
with the mythosar and the armor says
that since the mythosar belongs to all
mandalorians it's okay but Pokemon seems
a bit disappointed to hear this she
won't submit the star for herself she
asks the armor what if she actually saw
him at The Sword and the armor answers
only cryptically when you choose to walk
the way the Mandalore you will see many
things as if this was no more than a
noble Vision but she doesn't explicitly
do deny what bogoton saw was real either
so bogoton's faith in partaking in this
cult is transitioning from witnessing a
miracle to joining in the day-to-day
rituals and trials that truly test them
she is also a bit of a foundling that we
are left with in this episode but one
final detail that you might have missed
in the final frames while it seems like
bogoton is staring at the mythosar on
the wall the armorer steps in a frame
between them on the other side of that
fire watching bogoton closely I think
conflicts may be Brewing between bogoton
and the armor reminder to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive and he can
support us by grabbing some merch at
nerdrive.shop follow me on Instagram and
Twitter EA boss follow me rockstars And
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]